look at this look at me look at you our
first big adventure together look at us
a couple but why they have to be in this
busted desert Wasteland this is a great
name for a strip club but look at this I
wouldn't live here you know how you see
those signs that says if you lived here
you would be home
oh
hey don't get lost out here I feel like
it's gonna be pretty easy to get lost if
your ass don't pay attention pay
attention
talking practice these guys suck they
just eat up scrap metal and trust me
scrap metal tastes like [ __ ] I know you
can just kill these guys just kill them
foreign
[Music]
like a Black Friday sale you get there
late you miss all the good stuff you
don't have your size
[ __ ] is on the floor you know some
people are fighting over stuff
that's what the desert is no good [ __ ]
here
old Town's just past this bridge you
can't miss it
oh check out a little tiny City over
there oh hello there
I'm cutie Cutie and it's my great
pleasure to introduce you to little
cutie town
where a nice peaceful Society full of
cute little one-inch tall guys who love
each other and only know how to be nice
we welcome all standards with open arms
and a full heart I'm so so glad you
found your way to our sweet little Slice
of Heaven oh fantastic you've decided to
take a look around little cutie oh my
god oh oh no you just crossed our
hospital we have a state-of-the-art
healthcare program here in little cutie
town where everyone gets treated for
free that hospital was full of sick
people in mute and now they're all stars
oh my God this is this sucks so much
you're just walking around knocking down
buildings oh no no no no no no no I hate
seeing everyone I love dying oh no there
goes cutie Stephen you just get done
cutie Steve and you didn't even realize
it because you're so big you just step
up oh you're destroying our historic
monuments oh my God that's little cutie
Town Hall that's right okay that's it
that's my whole my whole town my whole
little cutie Town's ruins you've ruined
the whole city and All My Friends Are
Dead I'm the only last little cutie
alive and I had going to kill myself I
guarantee it as soon as you walk away
I'm gonna be so depressed I just popped
what gun in my own head and I die I'm
just gonna [ __ ] die how's that sound
no more living for me I don't want to be
alive my whole town home is gone and
dead and you did it it's your fault I
know I invited you in but you should
have realized you're so big you're gonna
ruin things you should have told me I
didn't think about it I'm kind of dumb
sometimes but you're you're not as dumb
as me I am I assume so you should have
said hey I'm not gonna go in there I
don't want beams have this spot but day
on whoa whoa whoa hey look walk away if
you want this is the [ __ ] mac and
cheese Brothers
you gotta be careful what whoa whoa
chill out we're cool okay so how you
want to handle this tough guys like this
only respect of a tough guys so don't
embarrass me you think you could just
walk up into a mac and cheese Brothers
construction site like you're some sort
of [ __ ] Jew oh whoa whoa you just
killed me Brothers
[Music]
I'm Jimmy mac and cheese and you killed
my brother Joey Mac and Cheese you know
he was important you know Joey I'll tell
you a little battle we'll do a little
eulogy here right shove yeah I hate you
upstairs
[Music]
you're a piece of [ __ ] alien I hate you
oh you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me here
we're gonna
holy [ __ ] those guys are intense you
know you could have killed them right I
would have been fine with that I think
[Music]
[Music]
all right Old Town we just moved through
this place and we'll get to Douglas
you you Snappers looking again to Old
Town hey we should talk to this guy I
calls him like I sees him he seems
helpful how did that partner welcome to
Old Town they call me old wet Grundy how
can I help you
so uh why do they call you all wet
Grundy it's cause I'm old and I piss
myself every day I'm doing it right now
you're pissing yourself while you're
talking to us oh yeah big time it's
still going oh this is good one
hey do you happen to know where we can
find a a guy named douglas douglas the
G3 fella
he's a rougher never seen somebody drink
as much as him why just last night
nobody I shouldn't speak out a turn the
G3 don't like that none and I don't like
them just head down a drag town I'm sure
you'll find them
all right
drag Town's past here I just stand
around and tell people that hey sorry
excuse me is I just curious is is uh
they're a fella named Douglas down there
like G3 Douglas uh yeah it's his job to
be down there I heard he was partying
pretty hard last night though
hey I can't let anyone
until they stop or get killed wink wink
are you telling us to kill them whoa I
didn't say that I just said wink wink
and okay yeah that's what I meant so go
kill him and I'll let you through
next time all right looks like things
have quieted down a little bit you know
thanks to us you know quite a team we
are anyways uh let's uh let's poke our
way into drag town now let's go to drag
town
you did it the town's all cleaned up I
keep tab until I don't know how many
times I've told the recruits Not to
cause trouble out there or if someone's
gonna kill them you're the one who had
us kill them Tomatoes potatoes just a
dumb gate guard whatever head on through
three really spruced up drag town you
can get anything you want down there
drugs sure sex yep those are the only
two things I could think of oh wait
laptops you can get laptops I bet drugs
sucks and laptops that's drag town baby
foreign
are you looking for Glory that join the
G3 cartel my name's Douglas the G3 chief
of training and torture ignore that
second bit for this ad this one's just
about the training
check it out that was Douglas we're hot
on this Trail
okay Douglas again this ad is about to
torture uh the last one was about
joining the G3 but this one is about how
I love torturing it's not an ad for
anything it's just like a reminder that
part of my job is also torturing people
enemies of the G3 random strangers who
looked at me funny anybody up
is part of the Mothers Against violence
treaty so no violence allowed here
mother's against violence huh I guess
things are going to be quiet around here
wow you can really tell the G3 run this
place huh
so like I was saying my brother told me
Douglas is really into torture like
sexually does it matter yes to me it
needs to be sexual why are you telling
me this I barely know you oh my bad yeah
just sort of spelled out well now you
know do us it what you will I'm not
doing anything
oh I hope we don't have to meet Douglas
yeah geez that guy scares the [ __ ] out
of me he was trying to play Gary alive
at the party were you guys at the party
last night I can't believe
and decided it would be fun to have a
few small sectors where we don't all
kill each other taking that view isn't
this place great the whole city hanging
under an asteroid you can really get
away with a lot of crime down here
hello there my child I'm from a sweet
little organization called mothers for
violence and you're about to enter a
sector under our jurisdiction that's
right there's Mothers Against violence
and then there's us mothers for violence
we're a little different we love
violence and we want more of it
everywhere
okay [ __ ] I guess let's just kill them
all
[Music]
we just globbed it all over the place
all right a heads up Warface
[Music]
this
happened to you
right oh glad we're in the mother's four
violence Zone I was missing your
violence
violence wow a real G3 training facility
maybe Douglas does the training in
person
hey hey you can trust me he's fine I'm
trustworthy I promise
hey Ada thanks for coming over here I'm
the goop guy around these parts you'll
want to sneak into G3 facilities yeah I
gotta get covered in goop that's just
how it goes my stuff's quality so you
want some goop right
uh you know what yes how about how about
a big fat yes let's go perfect head down
the alley there and just uh let the
magic happen I guess uh don't don't
worry your first goop's on me just tell
all your buddies about it I'm the goop
guy I do goop stuff
oof oh my god oh gee oh my God not not
what I was thinking it would be
oh oh this [ __ ] so my God the smell
oh my God I'm gonna [ __ ] throw up
okay okay I'm all right okay oh my God
look at you you're all gooped up I gotta
be honest it won't last long it's not
the real stuff so you better be quick
get in get out don't stay in there too
long don't roll the gig because this
stuff's gonna fall off that's the goop I
promise that's the guarantee you're 18
right by the way okay thank you let's
just go let's just go
oh looky here we got another gooped up
G3 recruit be advised that the G3 cartel
is not responsible for any
life-threatening injuries you may incur
on these premises that even if we were
we wouldn't give a [ __ ] who cares I hope
you get shot good luck thanks
are you [ __ ] kidding me they have
some whole thing prepared shut the [ __ ]
up it's starting
welcome welcome welcome I'm sure you
already know who I am but living under
under Douglas G3 chief of training and
torture and wouldn't you know it I
look to your left now look to your right
both of those people are gonna die today
you are about to jump right into an
accurate warp base simulation of what
it'll look like to be on the real
Battlefield and let me tell you you're
probably gonna die but hey if you don't
you get to join the G3 big whoop all
right that's it Lock and Load [ __ ] oh my
God is that you saw that right because
that was a Gatling Douglas has a galleon
we gotta rescue her Jesus these [ __ ]
merkeloids well [ __ ] here we go I [ __ ] I
hope it's not too difficult
foreign
[Music]
that was nothing good work buddy I guess
we're all done oh okay you beat all the
weak guys easy really easy let's not go
do the obstacle course oh okay
okay you know what it looks like some
simple platforming you know like but
you'd see in like Lucky's Tale on uh you
know or um you know that one uh that one
game really you got hurt yeah that
looked like it should have been easy
everybody
you know listen you're not gonna impress
me if you if you if you get through this
because it's pretty simple
okay let's just get this over with stop
messing up
oh [ __ ] well I guess it's apparently
harder than it looks one zap would kill
me
[ __ ] it get that [ __ ] jump God damn
that was a little that we we made it it
was a little tough though
congratulations [ __ ] so you made it
past the first training exercise big
deal was easy we lied and said it was
hard to scare you oh it's fun to freak
you out to [ __ ] with your head
your head for exercise too
that's right you have to wait a full
hour we're testing your resolve so just
stand there patiently and wait then this
door will open and you can continue
ah okay there's no way we're waiting a
full hour
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait are you really gonna wait
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
[ __ ]
oh okay sure you just okay finally oh
let's just bust out of here and have
some real fun let's get back to the real
fun
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] okay well there goes that
bootleg goop I guess that didn't last
for very long
[Music]
oh my God hello thank God you're here my
name's Dr jupy Douglas kidnapped my
whole family and I'm trying to sneak in
and save them but I just can't get
through these pipes in the Next Room oh
my God I'm freaking out Hey listen
little guy we're trying to find Douglas
too you know maybe we can help each
other God I'm so worried I'm gonna I'm
gonna throw up you really help me oh gee
I'm I'm so grateful follow me
[Music]
you gotta connect these pipes for me so
I can get through and save my family hey
don't worry this is a classic textbook
puzzle situation I think me and my
bounty hunter partner can figure this
one out don't even worry oh how wondrous
I'm forever in your debt I don't know
how I can ever repent
wow you did it you got the door open
listen I'll never forget this you're my
personal hero oh come on you're too
you're too kind it was easy oh did you
say you're heading to find Douglas too
his office is that big building up on
top of drag town but there's a zip line
just past here that'll take you right to
him
huh well all right then I I hope the guy
gets his family back
all right Douglas here we come that was
the hardest part behind us this is
basically done we finished this [ __ ] we
are fully out [ __ ]
okay what is this congratulations to all
of you worms who made it this far in
your training it is now time for the
final test a bloody free for all last
one standing gets to join the G3 no
rules just killing Good Luck [ __ ] heels
oh it looks like we don't have a choice
huh God damn get the shooting Bounty
Hunter blast they asses
good job congratulations recruit now uh
I don't know fight some more guys Jesus
Take the Wheel
gotta get out of here run
s whoa okay
you get so good you [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa we did it we're the number one G3
recruit we we we could be in the G3 if
we wanted to be whoa we could be if we
wanted to congratulations graduates on
joining G3 or whatever I really can't
stress enough how little I give a [ __ ]
now report to your commanding officer
and we'll send you off to die fighting
for us on whatever dumbass planet we
decide see ya
you there yes you The Savvy customer in
the helmet come on over here
totally get it
bought it great
see you around pal
am I glad to see you I'm so happy we
keep running into each other oh
what's up Dr jupy you mind if I call you
Dr J you're my favorite little guy Dr J
there's another locked door I'm running
out of time God I'm so worried about my
kids and a little bit about my wife but
mostly my kids oh puzzle another puzzle
huh puzzle time but let's take a little
crack at it how about that oh my poor
kids I hope Douglas doesn't kill them I
can feel my wife plenty calling for me
you're gonna solve this one too thank
you
oh
oh plimmy and the kids are probably so
scared without me Michael Douglas isn't
torturing them right now
amazing amazing you did it again
Douglas's office isn't too far from here
I'm going on ahead I'll see you there
Jesus Christ Douglas is gonna kill Dr
jupy look at look how weak and and cute
Dr jupi is forget about it
this is an urgent announcement this
sector has temporarily been designated
as a mother's four and against violent
Zone that means there's probably just
going to be a lot of violence and
intrusive
G3 recruitment program and there will be
a lot hey it's an [ __ ] who's been
[ __ ] with their training exercises oh
[ __ ] here we go
thank you
that's a beautiful slide that is just
the most amazing slide I've ever seen in
my life that is a beautiful slide
[Music]
don't [ __ ] with us
oh leave us alone
Club shots Reloaded
[Music]
foreign
you know what that's what they get for
joining the G3 you know I I guess I
don't I don't know it's I I'm I'm
conflicted on it it's rough
Dr chupi you're still alive
oh my best friends this is it Douglas is
Right Beyond this door can you help me
out one last time yeah let's do this oh
huzzah plimmy froopy Sloopy here I come